yes like this I really lack the
motivation to dress up in the button-up
and blazer I just what you're seeing is
a really tired ass man
who lacks the motivation to get dressed
for this Revere because that movie oh my
god that ship them to sleep yeah that
was brutal a lot of red to sorry about
that like the red background red shirt
all that anger that you're feeling right
now is because of this I for one
apologize for it I'm sorry let's just
talk about this movie
a huntsman winters war but the Huntsman
winters 4 is the spin-off I'm gonna call
a spin-off it's a pretty cool it's a
sequel it's a spin-off that no one was
really asking forward to Snow White
announcement snow white nuns been a
movie I actually enjoyed for what it was
I had fun with old weird dark twist on
the fairytale thing I enjoyed that [ __ ]
so now this movie comes out Emily Blunt
plays Elsa in this movie doesn't
actually play also she plays someone
else I don't even remember her
character's name in this movie don't ask
me to look it up cuz I lack the
motivation to look it up my brain lacks
the motivation to remember it just she's
the diet coke of Elsa
so Elsa in fact I'm very sure this movie
would not have existed without Freud
frozen never happened this movie
wouldn't have happened I gotta cash out
on some of that Elsa loves so alright so
diet coke Elsa's looking for the magic
mirrors it's gone missing so Chris
Hemsworth and a few dwarves and Jessica
Chastain have to get the mirror first or
else you'd really bad things you know
death destruction ice everywhere
standard fairy tale [ __ ] and alright
I've actually calmed down a little bit I
feel like I came into this review really
harsh know the movie did bore the [ __ ]
out of me but there was some neat things
in the movie had some neat fights neat
action the world was really lush there's
a scene where they're all just kind of
hanging out in the forest and the
animals are really cool-looking I almost
liked this movie it had I don't want to
say promise it had potential what is
potential really if it's not completely
wasted like they did in this movie I'm
going to take a scene that perfectly
illustrates the whole of this movie
alright there's this barroom brawl it's
actually a pretty sweet brawl everyone's
fighting is one scene a couple of guys
have Chris Hemsworth's arms and this
other guy comes up and starts punching
Chris Hemsworth in the stomach very next
cut Hemsworth is thrown out of the bar
into the rain and this guy comes up he's
walking over him and he hasn't actually
like ah you thought you'd win he's
taking him he's taunting him he's gonna
kill him but he doesn't is pretty early
on in the movie you know he's not gonna
die cuz it's called Huntsman it's like
in the title of the movie so Hemsworth
is fine here but the point is when your
friends had him bound had his arms back
like this why were you punching him in
the stomach and then had him thrown out
in the rain now you're taunting him with
an axe why not when your friends had his
arms back why not just take your action
just be like alright problem solved he's
dead buried in his chest buried in his
face there's no reason he should have
walked away from this situation but he
did but it's not like
hemsworth had the map to Skywalker in
his head and the bad guys needed him
alive there's no reason Hemsworth should
have walked away from that so dumb calls
like that and dumb editing choices
throughout this movie this movie has
romantic banter in attempts if the
action is not being thrown at the screen
everything is a failed attempt really
90% of attempted humor attempted
romantic banter and all of it falls flat
the humor falls flat the romantic banter
falls flat the scene with her in this
rowboat and I was like this is a Anakin
meet Padme cuz this is bad and this
movie I cannot stress this enough was so
boring I was yawning so much because
there's just a lot of walking and going
to and talking and I battled not more
walking like you know when Lord of the
Rings came out and you had that friend
who was like and there's kind of boring
just a lot of walking and talking but
Lord of the Rings is actually you know
[ __ ] good new characters Prime I can
go on and on but I have reviews of those
if you want to know my thoughts on Lord
of the Rings this is like everything
that your friend who didn't like Lord of
the Rings is bitching about Lord of the
Rings but he was wrong about translated
to this movie he'd be completely right
charlie sirens in the movie I guess kind
of why I don't know she's alive for the
sake of having her alive I thought she
was just gonna turn to the camera and be
like yeah Horcrux like Harry Potter
alright so now I'm here and to be clear
I don't know if it's a Horcrux it's just
no real she's alive because and emily
Blunt's in this movie alright here I did
this is just miss cast to the 10th to
grade she wasn't good in this role
because I took everything about Emily
Blunt and they just completely scrapped
it and they made her a lifeless little
hollowed frozen heart [ __ ] with no
emotion whatsoever which is fine if that
character calls for it I'm just saying
Emily Blunt shouldn't have been that
person because that's not where emily
Blunt's powerhouse performance comes
from having a character in a role that
bleeds Emily Blunt of anything that
makes Emily Blunt Emily Blunt is like
casting samuel l jackson as mace windu i
get it if they want to have this
emotionless somber person that's just
not the actor to do it you need like
female Christopher Walken someone who
just really thrives on their presence
and doesn't show emotion but that's
actually their strength I get actors
wanting to branch out and do other
things I'm just saying well now she
knows and now she can get back to being
the Emily Blunt that is really good and
stuff in fact I feel like if you swap
the female roles in this movie
feel like jessica chastain would have
made a better diet coke elsa and emily
blunt would have made a better warrior
woman in the movie who is seen from the
edge of tomorrow she kicks ass so why
not guys point is this movie was a wreck
it was a mess it was boring as [ __ ] it
did have some neat action sequences in
it and it did have some promise
especially near the end where they have
some charming sentimentality going on
but a complete waste but it's like 90%
waste I'm just saying the Huntsman
winters war not gonna remember this one
in t-minus one day yeah I already forgot
alright so here's a good question and
you got to really use your imagination
on this one given the fact that these
dark retellings of fairytales aren't
really working out the way studios want
them to work out what is a fairy tale
you would like to see have that happen
to it but you know done well whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more